des scènes quotidiennes dans les rues de
bangui la population en discussion très
animée avec les forces de l'ordre dans
le viseur le rôle des agents de la
minustah la mission des nations unies
pour le soutien à la centrafrique
critiqué pour son travail sur le terrain
un sentiment d'insécurité plane chez les
centrafricains et centrafrique
cela passe et c'est ce qui s'est passé
c'est ce qui a fait que les gens
manifestent aujourd'hui c'est qu'un
élève du lycée technique qui était en
train de partir à l'école a été renversé
par un véhicule de la minus cas il est
mort
les élèves et toute la population ont
manifesté leur colère aujourd'hui la
population est en train de souffrir
alors qu'ils ne font rien dans le pays
soit qu'à souffler un fait divers qui
n'a pas été confirmée ni démentie
officiellement mercredi matin du côté de
l'onu
un peu plus loin en proche de la
gendarmerie centrafricaine à notre
véhicule entièrement calciné est entouré
par des élèves du lycée technique armés
de cailloux et de bâtons ces dernières
heures plusieurs manifestations ont été
organisées au sein de la capitale
notamment sur trois principales avenues
des véhicules et des casques bleus ont
été prises à partie par des projectiles
la sécurité a donc été renforcée sous
investisseurs cela a créé un soulèvement
avec tout ce qui se passe dans
l'arrière-pays la minus cas ne fait rien
contre
ils sont juste là assez pavaner dans
bangui ils sont juste là à se pavaner
dans bangui au lieu de se rendre en
province pour sauver nos familles qui se
font massacrer
ils sont seulement ici ce que les élèves
demandent à travers cette manifestation
c'est le départ de la minurcat de la
centrafrique a team jusqu'à la
centrafique à la minus qu'à féliciter
pourtant par le président faustin
archange touadéra réélu dès le premier
tour fin décembre une élection
présidentielle perturbé par l'offensive
d'une coalition de six des plus
puissants groupes armés qui occupe
actuellement deux tiers du pays depuis
le début de la guerre civile il y a huit
ans des rebelles stoppés début janvier
aux abords de la capitale par les
casques bleus
bien aidé par des militaires rwandais et
para militaires russes venus
en renfort la réélection du président
touadéra finalement validés par la cour
constitutionnelle avec un taux de
participation de 35%
il y à un mois le conseil de sécurité de
l'onu a décidé d'augmenter de près de
3000 personnes les effectifs de la minus
cas déjà composé de douze mille cinq
cents hommes
objectif continuer à assurer la bonne
tenue des élections législatives et le
dernier déploiement des vaccins contre
le coronavirus